Hey Guys.
Colossians 3:2 says:
Set your mind on the things above,
not on the things of Earth.
You know if you do that
it changesyour whole life.
I think Togo agrees, look...
Chibi, do you agree?
It changes everything,
because you know,
you canargue about the silliest things
with your family
I cannot believe that there
are so many Christians
who call themselves Christians
and still,
they don't forgive
their family members.
Jesus said
that you have to forgive them.
If you don't want to forgive them,
then He's not going to forgive you.
And how can you not forgive them
after what Jesus did for you?
All the things that He forgave you...
Set your mind on the things above.
Think about the Eternal things
and not the temporary.
And lovethe people
around you.
Remember that always.